(audience cheering)
- Thank you so much.
- I love it when you come.
- I love being here.
- You're like a light.
You're one of those people.
- That's how I feel about you too.
And the last time I was
here there was no audience.
So this is like even--
- I know.
They were all screens last time.
- That's right.
- Or maybe no one was here.
I don't remember where we
were at COVID at that point.
But yeah, we kept some of the screens.
It's kind of cool.
- Yeah, it's cool.
- Yeah. You keep connected like with,
oh hey, what's up y'all?
(Alyssa laughs)
Well, last time you were
here, we both love animals
and I think you were about
to get new animals, right?
- I mean that's always
kind of a thing in my life.
Where I'm about to get new animals.
But yeah, I think the last time I was here
I was almost gonna adopt a mini horse.
But by the time that happened
- It happens.
- Yeah, as one does.
The horse was gone by the
time I said yes to it.
And had been adopted to a good home.
- Well that's good.
- Yeah. But I did get a new puppy.
- [Kelly] I got a new
puppy since I saw you.
- You did? What kind of puppy did you get?
- My daughter, oh my gosh.
- You could smell the puppy
breath from here, right?
Look at it.
- I, oh my God.
- That's Scout.
- Scout? What a great name.
- She is the best puppy.
I'm telling you, I've
never had a puppy like this
before in my life.
- I love that.
- Oh, and that's Bella, my daughter.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
Looking all cute and ready
for my ranch in Montana.
Okay. So our daughters are
actually the same age, so--
Oh my gosh.
I love snuggling with my
dogs, y'all. And my children.
But sometimes it's equal.
They're both equally
awesome to snuggle with.
'Cause they're just so furry.
So wait, what, what are you
what are your kids into these days?
- Slime. Which we were
talking about backstage.
My son is just a, an avid baseball player.
- Oh, that's cool.
- Yeah. Which is amazing.
And also he plays the
guitar and the drums.
My daughter's very into fashion.
She's also really into
- I noticed.
- She's also really into holidays.
Like the kid has never met
a holiday she doesn't love.
- Like in decorating and
stuff? Like getting--
- Everything.
- That's me.
- That's you?
- I love it.
And my son actually, my
six year old son loves it.
- Oh that's sweet.
Yeah, he, my son doesn't care.
- He literally tells me to
stop and move out of the way.
'Cause I'm in the way
of his decorating dream.
And his, like his vision.
- I love that.
- My daughter meanwhile is
like off watching YouTube.
- My daughter said to me the other night,
I got into bed with her and she said,
"Mom, the love fairy paid
a visit to your office."
- The love fairy?
- I said, what's the love fairy?
- She goes, "You know,
for Valentine's Day?
- Did she decorate her?
- She decorated my office, but
she didn't have decorations.
So they're all just like kind of handmade.
- Which is way better!
- Look, look, look at how cute.
- Oh my gosh!
"I made this." I love it, I love it.
So my favorite part of this picture is,
yes, your daughter is wonderful,
but also you are a beverage queen like me.
You have cold and hot, it looks like.
That's right.
That's exactly right.
- That's me, too.
- 'Cause you just never know.
- You just never know.
And sometimes you like to
mix it up and get crazy.
- And if I'm on a zoom,
like sometimes I wanna
be cool with my coffee.
And other times I wanna look
kind of healthy and sporty.
So I have my water.
- Oh, see mine is like,
I just don't know what the hell I want.
Like that's mine.
So I'm just like, I just like the options.
- Mine are props.
- Oh mine are totally
like, I just don't know
what I'm gonna be in the mood for
and I'm gonna be trapped
here for a minute.
So I just start getting, yeah I get--
Do you get that on planes?
I get that on planes.
I'm like, oh my god, I'm stuck here.
I get, I get like a, I freak out like
I'm not gonna be able
to like, what do I need?
And then I bring way
too much on the plane.
- Oh yeah. Then you gotta get
all settled.
- Why did I bring seven books?
I can't even finish one on this plane.
- Oh my god, that is so me.
- Because I don't know
which one I'm gonna wanna read.
- That's so me and you know
what else I started doing,
is bringing cleaning supplies.
- Yeah? Well that's COVID got us.
- Yeah. I wipe down everything now.
- You're my sister.
She travels with just a bag,
like some Mary Poppins of cleaning.
She's been like that since before COVID,
it's a problem.
But, but if you ever need
anything, she's there for you.
- She's there. She's got it.
- Yeah, she's got it covered.
But speaking of kids, you
posted this on Instagram.
And in the caption you
talk about thinking a lot
about the lasts that
you have with your kids.
So has that been tough for you?
'Cause recently this happened with my son.
He didn't, he was like, I was like, wait
are we not gonna snuggle like before bed?
And he was like, no.
And I was like, (whimpers) it's fine.
I was like, it's totally fine.
They just stop all a sudden.
- Yes. And it starts with breastfeeding.
Like my son at nine months
just stopped breastfeeding
and I remember just being like.
- Why don't you want me?
- Well, not only did I
feel totally rejected,
but I remember regretting
years later, I was like,
oh my God, I don't remember
the last time I breastfed him.
And so with Bella I was
constantly, you know,
every time I breastfed I was,
I was like just taking in the moment.
My baby, this has been
the most rewarding thing
I've ever done is breastfeed you, my baby.
- Meanwhile she's like, my mom is a freak.
She's like, like what's happening?
- She lasted for two years.
And I do remember the
last time I breastfed her.
We were in a mommy and me class
and there was a loud sound
and she walked over to me.
She was two, and she said, "Mama, chichi."
Which is what she adoringly
called my breasts.
And, and I breastfed her
and she never asked again.
- Just on her own, just
never asked again? Yeah.
You're lucky though, 'cause
a lot of women, like my self,
I had like a, I have like a
couple like autoimmune things.
This is what I think
hindered me being able to,
but I could only do it for so long.
And then it just like, whoop!
Dried up. Desert. Yeah.
- I mean that happens.
You know, we all do
the best that we can.
- That's awesome, yeah.
I know, I was just like,
are you done? Alright.
- That's okay.
- They got all the good stuff,
but I was just like, I, yeah.
You're lucky that that happened for you.
- Yeah, but don't feel bad.
- I didn't honestly, it hurt,
and I was really celebrating it.
- Right. Yeah.
I don't think moms should
ever feel bad about,
we're all trying to do
the best that we can.
- And all our bodies are different.
- All of our bodies are different.
What baby needs is different.
- But that's incredible.
Just scientifically, it's not,
they've done studies
on how that, you know,
like how it helps kids and how, you know,
that's really cool.
I love that for you.
So you're celebrating a major milestone.
It's been 20 years since you started
as an ambassador for UNICEF.
That's incredible.
How did you end up, 20
years is a long time.
Was there something that
happened in your life
that made you wanna be
a part? Like why UNICEF?
- Yeah. Well, in 2000,
I lived in South Africa
for three months and I was filming--
- Wait, why? Oh, you were filming.
- I was filming,
but I had a very small
part in this in this movie.
So I would, I would go
volunteer in like townships
and children's hospitals.
And when I got back to LA,
I had such a hard time assimilating
the person that I discovered
there, which was this
you know, very empathetic, compassionate--
- And you can't unsee certain things.
- Person of service.
I realized that serving other
people is what fulfilled me.
And when I came back, I went
through a really hard time
of depression because I
was like on "Charmed",
living in a house in Beverly Hills,
you know, driving a BMW
and I had just seen such hardship
and there was a lot of guilt in that.
And my mom said to me,
because she was a a huge fan
of UNICEF's lifesaving work,
and did trick or treat for
UNICEF when she was a kid,
and then I did it.
She said, "you should call UNICEF."
And so in 2003 they, they
appointed me as an ambassador
and I've been able to
travel to Angola, Africa.
Two years after the
peace treaty was signed
for the longest civil war
in the history of the world.
India, six months after the tsunami,
to see how UNICEF was
helping communities rebuild.
Uh, Kosovo, where I learned about,
really, the disparity in
income and how poverty
impacts a child's development and future.
- Obviously, yeah.
- And then recently I went to Egypt
where my focus was on young girls
and there's still some,
some practices in Egypt
like female genital
mutilation that UNICEF,
with with the government, is
really trying very hard to ban.
So, so it's really just very fulfilling.
Hard work, but important work.
And I feel very blessed
that I am still able to
be a person of service.
- Yeah. I mean it's, it's the
most incredible thing, right?
'Cause you're super blessed in your life
and you get these opportunities.
But to use that spotlight
and for someone that might,
you know, like, "Oh I love her,
"and oh my God, she's into
that, what does that mean?"
Like, you know what I'm saying?
It is a very cool thing
to use that spotlight.
So thank you for doing that.
Do you think, 'cause I feel like
you do get political in a good way.
Do you feel like you'd
ever get into politics?
Would you ever do that?
- You know, I think it is something,
if I can figure out a
way to run for office
and still maintain my integrity.
Which I'm not sure is, is
something that you can do.
I think think that,
I think people--
- That's the saddest statement
but so true, yeah.
- I think that our politicians get into it
for the right reasons and on both sides
get very caught up in the power of it.
- Or even how to get out
there. Like to have support.
- It's such a bureaucracy.
And they're constantly fundraising
and they go where the money goes
and it's just very easy to get,
I think, caught up in all of that.
I'm an activist.
I'm happy to be an activist
and I feel like I get a lot done.
If at some point I could figure out
how to get as much done
and run for office.
I'm not saying no.
- Against the idea.
- And also my kids are little.
And you have to be in DC so much.
So maybe as they get older.
- Well everybody who's running for office
if you ever do this,
they need a good motto.
And I love, this quote inspires you,
and I love this quote,
I've heard it before.
But if you haven't, it's great.
It says "They tried to bury us,
"but they didn't know we were seeds."
Which I think is so powerful.
What does that say to you?
I've heard this before and I love it.
- For me, I feel like personally,
because I get attacked by so many trolls.
And they've tried to
cancel me so many times,
that every time I, they,
they try to cancel me,
I feel like I grow back stronger.
And also they're spreading my message
by talking about it.
- By talking about it.
- So that's what it means to me.
But I think, I think it's a
beautiful thing, you know?
Especially for, you know,
to teach kids when when things are hard
and people are mean or whatever.
Or when people are mean, just
think of yourself as a seed.
You are, they're planting
a seed for you to grow.
And I think that's what
activism is mainly, anyway.
Right? Like I think
about all these activists
that didn't get to see certain
things in their lifetime.
Like Alice Paul who wrote
the Equal Rights Amendment,
which is like my grave, my grave tombstone
mission.
- What you want on there.
- It's the thing that I need
to accomplish in my life.
But she wrote it a
hundred years ago. Right?
And we're still fighting for the ERA,
which is basically women being included
in the constitution or
named in the constitution.
Right now, women,
85% of people do not realize that women
are not included in the constitution.
We are the only industrialized nation.
Which is so--
- Which is so crazy.
'Cause we're known as
possibly the progressive one.
- But I, yeah.
I look at Alice Paul and I think, wow.
- A hundred years later, still.
- A hundred years later.
And she didn't get to see
all that hard work come into fruition.
How can I be okay with my hard work
not coming into fruition?
And at a certain point, you have to be
just so in love with the
process of trying to make change
that you realize you're planting the seed.
You're planting the seed
that hopefully will grow.
- I think that's the
thing. It's not overnight.
It's not overnight. So
that's the thing, too.
Well especially for her. But I just mean
it's not overnight.
- Especially for women.
- People wanna see it the next day
and it's like, that's
not it. It's a grind.
Like anytime you want change,
it's gonna be a grind.
And you might not even see it.
But like we have kids,
you want that for them.
I want these rights for them.
You know?
So I think that's where we
need to start thinking like,
it's not just about your direct impact.
It's about everyone's direct impact.
And what's helpful for all of us.
- Well and also kids
and young people today
are the generation where everything
is immediate gratification, right?
They could push a button
and it shows up to
your house the next day.
- Oh my God.
you just described my daughter, yeah.
- Right? Like the addiction of it.
And it starts at a very young age.
And I think kids' mental health
is actually really taking
a hit because of it.
- That's why it should be included
in the curriculum in schools.
- I agree!
- Yeah, I know.
I talk about it all the time.
People are annoyed with it, probably.
We need another break,
but go online to learn more
about UNICEF, everybody.
And also I want to mention that Alyssa
has a new movie coming out.
It's called "Who Are You People?"
It's in theaters, great title,
and on demand starting February 24th.